In the course of adapting their comic book
properties to film and TV, Marvel has made
some pretty big changes to their classic characters.
While some changes have been for the best,
others have risked losing the magic that made
those characters great in the first place.
Crack open a longbox and take a look at how
these Marvel characters should really look.
Daredevil
Netflix's Daredevil series keeps to gritty,
street-level heroics instead of the usual
globe-trotting Avengers fare, so naturally,
producers were nervous about undermining this
realistic approach with simple red spandex.
Daredevil spent most of the first season fighting
crime in cargo pants and a black handkerchief
mask, all without his famous double Ds.
When he finally donned a superheroic costume,
the comics' vivid red color scheme skewed
more maroon, and most notably, the traditional
skintight costume was ditched in favor of
reinforced leather, accented in black.
It's more armored than what we've seen in
the comic pages, probably because getting
hit by nunchucks and swords really hurts.
And by the end of the first season, Daredevil
finally gets the bright idea to wear a horned
helmet instead of, well, nothing.
Let's not even touch this guy's ridiculous
first comic appearance...which pretty much
proved he was totally blind.
Elektra
The biggest problem with comic book Elektra
is that no self-respecting female warrior
would be caught dead fighting in a skintight
swimsuit in the real world.
And Elektra, for some reason, is usually drawn
covered in so many wafting scarves that she
looks like Steven Tyler's microphone stand.
She's the very definition of an impractically
dressed assassin.
She never even has a place to put her sais.
Give the poor woman a holster or something,
at least.
Jeans, a sleeveless shirt, and a mask to hide
her identity?
That's far more in line with practical assassin
gear, and live-action Elektra wears it well,
opting for the same real-world practicality
as Matt Murdock.
Though we'll see how crazy things can get
if Elektra somehow returns for season three.
Luke Cage
He may have never adopted the skintight getup
popular with other superheroes, but Luke Cage's
original outfit was still pretty goofy, featuring
a silver headband and a yellow blouse open
to the waist.
While that look undoubtedly killed at Studio
54, it didn't outlast the '70s.
By 1992, it was considered so cringeworthy
that Luke was shown tearing it to pieces on
the cover of his own comic.
However, it does get a fun shout-out in the
TV series, which sees Luke grab a yellow shirt
to wear while still sporting the metallic
headpiece and cuffs from the experiment that
gave him superpowers.
Live-action Luke Cage prefers darker clothes
and hoodies, which wasn't simply an aesthetic
choice.
Star Mike Colter told MTV News that the dark
hoodie was...
"...symbolic because of Trayvon Martin.
We talked about that specifically, what that
would mean to people and the feelings it would
evoke in viewers.
[...] What this show says politically resonates
profoundly."
Kilgrave
The nemesis of Jessica Jones, the Purple Man
is arguably one of Marvel's most terrifying
villains.
Originally a spy named Zebediah Killgrave,
a chemical accident turned his skin purple
and gave him the ability to command complete
obedience.
In Jessica Jones, Kilgrave keeps his mind
control powers and the suit, but loses the
comic book backstory and purple skin.
His "Purple Man" nickname is never mentioned,
and even "Killgrave" turns out to be an alias
used to hide his sinister true identity: Kevin
Thompson.
Without purple skin, Kevin looks like everyone
else, hiding his nightmarish powers in plain
sight, which is arguably much more terrifying.
Plus, it's easier just to make him look like
a perfectly unremarkable evil British guy,
who kind of looks like he's a candidate for
being the next Doctor Who.
The Punisher
It's kind of hard to mess up the Punisher
— just dress an angry guy in a black T-shirt
and hand him a gun.
Luckily, Jon Bernthal not only looks the part,
but does a spectacular job of portraying a
damaged soldier mentally spiraling downward
in the wake of immense tragedy.
Anybody in a skull shirt and leather can pass
for a decent Frank Castle, but to be able
to make The Punisher believable?
That's much harder to pull off.
Bernthal might not always sport the iconic
skull, but even without it, the guy is unmistakeable.
"Now I can ask you face to face.
Who was there that day?
Who killed my family?"
The Kingpin
Kingpin's traditional purple pants and white
jacket never made it beyond a quick reference
in the first season of Daredevil, probably
because the outfit is completely ridiculous.
Comic book Kingpin's ascot also seems to be
an upper-crust fashion relic that didn't make
it into the new millennium.
In its place around Vincent D'Onofrio's neck
is…nothing.
Not even a tie.
Instead, Wilson Fisk wears the finest suits.
Then again, he could be wearing clown shoes,
boxer shorts, and a tank top, and he would
still look like Kingpin.
There are few actors on Earth who'd look better
in the role.
Netflix and Marvel must thank their lucky
stars everyday for the gift that is D'Onofrio.
"And when one comes across someone with such
talent, with such a gift.
Well, you don't let that go to waste."
"No.
No, you don't."
The Owl
Leland Owlsley underwent the biggest comics-to-screen
change of any Daredevil character.
In terms of personality, both are financiers
of criminal enterprises, but beyond that they
differ wildly.
Netflix's Leland is a bespectacled and bow-tied
walking suit.
Comic book Leland, or the Owl as he's better
known, looks so much like Wolverine that it's
not difficult to mistake the two animal-themed
weirdos.
Older versions of The Owl look a lot more
whimsical, sporting a green, Sherlock Holmes-like
Ulster coat, and occasionally, he wore a big
ridiculous red bowtie around his neck that
made his head look like an extravagantly wrapped
Christmas gift.
It's also not clear if Daredevil's stuffy,
nerdy Owl had hollow bones, deadly talons,
or the ability to glide...but we're guessing
not.
Thanos
The evil alien overlord Thanos has already
made a big impact in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe, despite standing up for only about
30 seconds.
His love of sitting is very true to the comics,
where the character's inventively named "Space
Throne" can travel between dimensions.
Compared to the comics, Thanos' costume has
been updated to give him a more armored look,
replacing skin-tight space spandex.
The blue-and-gold color scheme remains, and
his helmet is now a separate piece instead
of being connected to the neck plate.
The character's traditional purple complexion
actually did make an appearance in The Avengers,
but was replaced with a milder blue by Guardians
of the Galaxy.
Maybe he just needs to work on his space-tan.
Loki
Tom Hiddleston's Loki has mostly stuck close
to the source material, although he's yet
to match his comic equivalent's gleeful mischievousness,
like turning Thor into a frog, for example.
His costume remains fairly faithful to the
comics, and even his famous horned helmet
makes a few appearances.
The main change is the same one most comics
adaptations make: switching Loki's classic
skintight catsuit for something a little less
revealing.
The costume has also been toned down a little,
with darker greens and less vivid gold trimmings.
That said, Loki is a shapeshifter, spending
notable periods of the comic as a child, a
woman, a magical unicorn, and he can even
pop off his own head when he feels like it...so
it's hard to say for sure what the character
should really look like.Thanks a lot for being
totally unpredictable, Loki!
"No, thank you."
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know what
you think about the costumes of Marvel's on-screen
heroes...